part four is so full of some crazy
incredible episodes i can't tell you too
much
but there does involve a first kiss
singing and acting are the two things
that i really love to do and i get to
throw in a little bit of dancing too
cut the crust off my bread
yes there it is yes jordan
we're gonna be okay
[Music]
packages of course we got part three and
you know fans are
already yearning for part four
so what can you tell me about part four
of family reading god
part four is so full of some crazy
incredible episodes
which i'm very excited for which is
another musical episode
uh but this time it's
pretty insane it's original but it is um
familiar loosely your people will be
familiar with
the story but we've completely kind of
reconstructed it
and and built it around the characters
that everybody knows and family reunion
jordan i want to ask you if you could
describe
part four of family reunion in three
words
what would you choose long hilariously
part four's episodes were one of some of
the longest ones we'd ever filmed
the big musical one i was on set until 3
a.m
yep elf i was sliding down a slide
at 3 a.m and i remember i was like this
is the life i had always wanted
i i i must look crazy i'm like crazy you
i i wanna of course talia ask you about
your character
jade she has a little romance this
season with
mr dion what was it like seeing jade be
in this new relationship
it's interesting obviously i'm excited
to see anytime jade has a little
crush don't make the fun of mostly every
episode
she always it literally is
um and obviously we've seen jade get
pretty ecstatic over
all of her guys but dion is different
you'll get to see him and her and and
how they just navigate their friendship
into a relationship and just getting to
know each other and having fun and
they're gonna deal with you know
boyfriend drama
but they're very good for each other and
there's some
really funny ones that we shot there's a
lot of barbecue sauce involved
and ketchup and puffy bird on my face
so yeah so do you think dion and jade
are end game do you want to see them
together
at least for a while i want to see jade
happy
you know i want to see the girl get what
she deserves
and just get to have her little happy
ending and you know what
if it's dion if it's not dion whoever it
is i just hope he treats her right
and i hope she doesn't have to stress
out and i hope her parents approve
because that unfortunately has become
quite
quite an issue yes it has yeah i just i
just want to add something to your
character
yes she's a player yes she might be
she might be but you know what jordan i
don't think she's a player i think she
just
she doesn't know how to make her mind a
lot of fish in the georgia sea
and salia i love that message i love
that your team jade
maybe she wants to focus on herself or
maybe she wants to get married whatever
she chooses
whatever she wants to do it's jason
jordan
cameron and isaiah are you guys
interested in maybe having some
romantic storylines bubble up or yeah i
actually i actually do
it it hasn't really come out yet i can't
tell you too much
but there does involve a first kiss
that's that's
all i'm gonna say so isaiah you have a
girlfriend
yeah yes yes i do in the show
okay okay so on the show you have a
girlfriend
yes yes i do she's played by jada marie
from julian the phantoms
also on netflix also on netflix oh my
gosh i'm so excited
jordan and cameron do you want to see
your characters
have any sort of romance no well
i mean jordan and jordan said no um
i mean i just i mean if it's a good fit
for my character then yes i would like
to see it i would just like to see
my character just continue to grow and
just follow what he loves to do
and just continue to be happy
[Music]
the big musical episode you guys
literally kick off part three
with a bang a full-blown musical cameron
i want to ask you
um we get to see you dancing and and
singing a lot in part three what did it
feel like to get to show off
your true showmanship on the show and is
this because you're putting a buzz in
meg's ear how did this all happen
i'm definitely really grateful for meg
that she wrote all of these moments and
all of the writers that um
allowed me to do this because that's
because singing and acting are the two
things that i really love to do and i
get to throw in a little bit of dancing
too
so and just getting just to do it all
with like the family just a whole big
musical number that scene was just so
much fun to shoot
isaiah of course you're right there
alongside cameron and the rest of the
cast what is it like for you to get to
flex
what is it like man it's great i'm so
excited
that i got to do more about more of that
and got to well see myself on tv doing
more of that
i'm really grateful that the writers let
me do that because not a lot of people
get to do the flips without a stunt
double
oh my god you're maya angelou you must
live your own life follow your
own dreams of the sun talia you get to
portray
maya angelou i want to know everything
about this experience what did it mean
to you
how did you prepare i just started out
by watching
so many youtube videos of her and and
studying her poems and her work
and what she stood for as a woman was so
inspiring and i was the last scene of
the day that we shot
there was barely anybody on set and the
lighting was beautiful
and the outfit was incredible and the
hair and the makeup and just
being able to portray such an inspiring
strong woman of color let alone uh was
just such an incredible experience
i watch you every episode and you bring
so much joy and
laughter and you know to watch you be
maya angelou was that emotional at all
for you definitely
my biggest inspiration is life is is are
women who
stand with themselves and for themselves
and and believe that they
are everything they are without
you know taking others opinions and
toxifying their own self-image and i
think my angela is
a perfect perfect image of a woman like
that
cameron and isaiah you guys got to play
gregory and maurice hines
isaiah were you familiar with the heinz
brothers and and what did it feel like
to
capture their essence oh yes i did know
who they were it felt
great to capture their essence as you
said um
we got to portray two amazing tap
dancers
just getting to learn like the tap dance
like at first it was just like whoa this
is what we're gonna be doing
and i remember when the choreographers
they performed it for us like on the set
and they were like this is what you guys
are gonna be doing
we watched them we were like wow so yeah
getting to
just put ourselves in the moment and
doing that really just felt like we were
performing for a bunch of people in this
hotel
and it felt like i was transported back
to that time so it was definitely a
great experience
i want to ask you jordan you're in this
amazing episode with some of the real
housewives
okay um meet princess rich skyler
and cousin kenya's niece jersey
charmed mutual had you even heard of the
real housewives before you shot this
oh yes thanks to my mom
oh yes yes literally
like if i have nothing to do when i'm
bored i will literally sit on the couch
and watch my mom
play like the real housewives and my
mom's like
dude go do something else no too bored
i'm staying here
you throw shade you tackled candice
and you ripped off brandy's wig so
i'm curious what did all of that feel
like shooting that scene in the moment
it was amazing i've always wanted to wig
snatch someone
yes it's going to be like natural
girl you did it you did it and you you
brought
such huge laughs oh you coming from my
mama
long road wrong road wrong
road i want to ask you jordan about
twinning with tia
you got to wear that fabulous outfit
what did it feel like
itchy wardrobe when miss keisha puts me
in a dress i'm like why are you
why do you do this to me jordan i hate
dressing up jordan i just want to ask
because you have so many amazing
lines in that which one is your favorite
cut the crust off my bread
yes there it is yes jordan
cut the crust off my bread boo
isaiah i want to ask you you have a
really cool story line with
tia's brother in real life taj mahari
class let's make our newest student feel
welcome
no no no in english
working with taj was a great experience
he is so
funny we definitely connected and
created a bond during that episode
we had a lot of fun it was definitely of
similar humor for sure
oh yes at the one thing yes isaiah is
always
pulling pranks and joking around and i
was just very similar to that
yes like especially he actually got me
back on that day
for scaring him yeah oh i gotta know
about this did you scare taj
i was hiding behind his door he was
watching
a rehearsal and i got him right there i
said ha
and he he got scared and ran he ran
so the next day i'm downstairs getting
ready
to rehearse he's right next to the table
and i'm walking by him don't even see
him he said
i'm like oh my gosh wait what what just
happened i think you saw some of that
when you came on set last year
i sure did
[Laughter]
my last question for you about taj you
know he's had such an incredible career
he
started young similar to how you have
isaiah did you have a chance to ask
him advice or wisdom about growing up in
this industry
oh yes i did yes i did i want to be an
actor throughout my whole life so
he told me about what it would be like
to well grow up in the business
um he told me what it'd be like to like
handle rejection stuff like that
was there one thing he told you that
like really stuck with you and maybe has
even helped you along the way
uh character you know being kind to
everybody who walks on the set
being generous thoughtful being a
thoughtful actor not trying to steal the
scene from everybody
you know let everybody shine that's so
important okay
can i get a show of hands from all four
of you who's on tick tock who loves
watching tick tock videos who's into
tick tock
the reason why i asked about tick tock
is because
you were lucky enough to get baby ariel
on family reunion
part three hi gingy let me apologize for
these people who i'm related to
i love you who's a huge fan what was it
like having her as part of this
really fun pop star story line it was
definitely a really funny storyline that
was funny
i definitely knew who she was before so
it was really cool just getting to have
her on set
being the mckellens and being awkward
around her so it was just
really really fun you almost got a kiss
from baby ariel what was it like filming
that moment
it was it was weird it was kind of
awkward because they
they actually they almost tricked me
into doing it but
thanks to covet i couldn't so wait is
that the reason why
the characters ultimately don't kiss
it's because
we're supposed to would that have been
your first on-screen kiss
yep wow that's a big moment
it would have been my first kiss like
period and my first on-set kiss
were there any tick tock dances that
were going on in between takes were you
able to like record anything with her
we made like a like a movie trailer on
imovie with her
and did anything i just did i i created
the movie trailer and put everyone in it
did you post this uh no i haven't but i
will
okay we're going to see this interview
and i think all the fans are going to
comment
isaiah post the the movie trailer
oh i definitely will i also did a tick
tock with a
baby ariel to that uh what you know
about love song you
get what you please we about to get it
this is a complete sidebar but i feel
obligated to bring it up because the
fans can't seem to get over this
cameron and isaiah so in real life
cameron you're older than isaiah but on
the show
shaka is older than mozzie do you guys
see the fans talking about this on
social media and on youtube
all the time the time all the time
you're always in our comments like i'm
so surprised cameron is older than
isaiah
how does this happen your bond your
friendship how has it changed and grown
over the last
two years two three years since you
started working together
well it's definitely cool just to have
someone on set that's close to my age
and
we feel like brothers we're in school
together most of us
are together shaka and mozi are always
up to something so yeah just
getting to play brothers makes us feel
like brothers in real life
it's not just shocking mazzy up to
something it's isaiah
cameron jordan when i spoke with you
on the set of family reunion two years
ago i asked you about your relationship
with your on-screen mom
tia and you very adorably started to cry
i'm about to have you cry
what has tia done for you she has been
very helpful for me
she's always done these nice things for
me
that's so sweet now that you've worked
with tia
for you know two and a half three years
how has your relationship with her
changed it has grown a little bit bigger
she sometimes feels like my stepmom or
just a mom in general
and it's amazing what has she taught you
about becoming an actress
and and life she's mostly taught me
like a lot of things on set
and it's actually really coming in she
feels like a very motherly figure on and
off camera
so it's something that we're all really
appreciative of
sort of making sure we're all okay and
just yeah
we got food and we ate and we have water
and things are good
have any of you binge sister sister
since it's
gone on to netflix in the last few years
i went through two seasons in a day is
it strange to see your on-screen mom
on screen when she was your age it's
crazy
it is it is crazy it is definitely
different i think like a lot of us had
seen sister sister and like twitches and
stuff
before shooting the show and then like
after you
obviously developed a relationship with
tia and
you shoot with her all these times and
then re-watching it
it's like oh my god now i'm seeing like
the tia i know
and then i'm seeing like the little tia
who was just doing what we do
[Music]